hey Morty quick favor. What, cover me in
gasoline and spiders fine yeah I'm in
wasn't my first pitch but hey not going to
waste this opportunity. Welcome back
everyone it's Charlie congratulations
you made it rick and morty season 4
is here this is going to be my episode 1
video I'll be doing Easter eggs for the
entire season be sure to subscribe to
get everything if you're new to the
channel and we do a weekly merch
giveaway careful for spoilers from the
episode if you have not seen it yet but
top 10 and Easter eggs would just do
Easter eggs as we go along because there
was so many so many fourth wall breaks
because it was the first episode of the
season and a really awesome post-credits
tag the title of the episode edge of
tomorrow rick die repeat was a
reference to edge of tomorrow the Tom
Cruise movie which is based on a
Japanese manga called all you need
where he goes out repeatedly thousands
of times till he can find the right
sequence of events that will allow time
to move forward so that his life can go
on just like Rick ends a bunch of times
during the episode and Morty is
constantly seeking the right course of
events to take so that he can achieve
his intended outcome but starting with
number 10 Morty is stalking Jessica on
her Instagram account and they used the
opening scene to let you know how the
power dynamic has shifted from the end
of season 3 rick is no longer able to
just drag Morty on any adventure that he
wants he has to get a measure of consent
they also kind of explain how things are
going to work at the end of the episode
- when they do their big rant that's a
big callback to season 1 they also use
this scene to tee up the idea that rick
has implanted chips in a lot of
different people he talks about the chip
and Morty's spine later in the episode
because of the Holograms that are super
PC but he also has the chip in his brain
that gives the automated responses
Rick's automated response is also a bit
of a callback to season 3 episode 2
where he put robot Morty and robots
summer there with Beth so that she
wouldn't know what was going on and they
could go do whatever they wanted to
speaking of season 3 episode 2 hardcore
summer episode this scene is also a
reminder of how hardcore she is because
all she wants is that funeral selfie
doesn't care if Jerry dies and doesn't
care that Jessica's grandmother died
either number 9 was the new season 4
intro there's a whole bunch of new intro
scenes with a bunch of Easter eggs they
always switch the order for which ones
are real which ones are fake but Justin
has also said in the past that they're
all meant to be real see
it's just that they haven't done those
episodes yet if they have 70 more
episodes including all the season 4
stuff then eventually they probably will
get to a lot of that stuff but it starts
with Rick flying into a space battle in
the vacuum of space with only a breather
towards this monster version of Morty in
orbit destroying everything in his path
with all these different space factions
then there's the Terminator parody with
all the snakes the t800 snake tomater
coming to save them just as the other
Terminator snakes trying to attack them
in the garage the reason why I know this
is probably real is because last week I
posted a trailer with different footage
from a future episode that also had more
terminator snake parody scenes then
Morty falls into a dream world crashing
through some psychic barrier that looks
like it's right out of Flash Gordon or
an adventure serial while Rick is
getting his face beaten in by this
person this whirring very Infinity
Gauntlet looking gloves on his hands
giant Morty's going all crackin from
Clash of the Titans on these aliens from
season 3 episode 5 were literally
conspiracy those aliens were
normal-sized during that episode so I'm
assuming that Morty here is meant to be
super huge the last new intro scene
seems like it's a reference to the
untitled goose game with the two-headed
goose coming for them and Rick revealing
that he has hidden weapons stashed in
the fridge if you remember back to
season 3 episode 6 he has weapons
stashed all over the house everywhere
number 8 Rick teaches Morty about the
death crystals explaining that they show
you your potential deaths based on your
current course of actions which is why
they show you so many at once but they
always change because your choices are
always changing so your future is always
going to be different if you pause and
look at these you can see so many
different versions of their deaths the
animation director for the episode said
that only about 40 of these made it into
the actual episode 40 different versions
of their deaths but they thought up way
way more version but probably the most
interesting one is when they bring back
squatchy you see up in this scene here
where he's ripping Rick to shreds so for
everybody hoping the Squatch he was
going to come back they totally did it but
nobody trusts squatchy this season but
Rick diving to protect Morty from the
laser fire is just another example of
how he really does care about him
despite the fact that he's so pissed off
about the shifting power dynamic and
have to get permission to take Morty on
adventures now Rick kind of breaks the
fourth wall but he's
splaining how it's okay for them to
treat the galaxy like their personal
piggy bank unlike the crystal poachers
when he refers to them as Rick and Morty
we're Rick and Morty butthis Morty grabs
one of the crystals and sees his future
with Jessica he accidentally gets Rick
so number seven Rick's
contingency plans in the super super PC
hologram they explain the backup chip to
c-137 Rick installed in Morty's spy
without telling him so you also wonder
how else has he been modified but they
sort of set up the running joke about
the hologram being super PC hologram
rights which is actually a concept that
they dealt with on Star Trek Voyager one
of the writers on Rick and Morty is also
doing a brand new animated Star Trek TV
show called lower decks so anytime
there's a really specific Star Trek joke
I always wonder if he had something to
do with it the holograms were sort of
the flip side of the coin from the
really awful that Rick kept
running into like they were really bad
but the super PC hologram wound up being
just as bad in the end my favorite
hologram gag was the weed Rick one when
they were at school full-blown
protesting him just going completely off
book come on Berkeley get with the
program number six turns out project
Phoenix really was the fallback that
Rick thought it was during season two we
find out that it's capable of routing
him to other dimensions and other clones
of other rigs from other realities so
even though he got rid of his clones
during season two there are so many
other Rick's and other dimensions that
did not he winds up in Rick's
clone body and they sort of set up the
running gag of all the terrible worst
versions of reality is that he winds up
in is it part of the idea with this with
him going to all the different terrible
realities was that because he's traveled
the finite curve so much he knows which
realities are worse than others
and they wanted to put him in the worst
possible situations so that's why he
shows up first naked in the basement of
Rick the worst possible situation
that he would have to deal with before
he can get home he also breaks the
fourth wall again when he tells them
that he took his own program offline a
couple seasons ago Rick has known that
he's been in a fictional TV show since
season one but if you look in the
background you can also see some Easter
eggs for things that the animators added
on the walls or IP China this is a
version of our president that we saw him
fight last season and if you look at the
boxes on the shelves here is actually
written as
as time travel stuff is if they have to
remind themselves of their political
leanings the alternate morti also kind
of breaks the fourth wall when he forces
Rick to go on an adventure with him
saying stop doing meta commentary and
then Rick goes again wakes up in shrimp
Rick's clone body but the twist is is
this another reality we find out
that mr. goldenfold is writing all kinds
of weird stuff on the board there's a
phallus over here maybe he drew this on
purpose maybe not because if you look
over here he also uses asses to talk
about basic arithmetic the crystal takes
Morty out of class and runs into a bully
that looks like he's a parody of Billy
from stranger things but he's voiced by
Dan Harmon who then references Pixar's
koko number 5 morty gets his hands on
all bricks weapons and they turn it into
more of an Akira parody so if you've
never seen akira basic premise is is
Tetsuo is an esper whose powers start to
grow out of control until he turns into
this giant amorphous blob at the end of
the episode which Morty winds up doing I
give him a whole bunch of bonus points
in this episode for creative use of
meeseeks not just the red meeseeks but
Morty goes way overboard
they said part of the reason for using
so many meeseeks especially this giant
army scene is because the whole concept
is is that Rick hates being derivative
in repeating himself but morty makes
those mistakes all the time so all these
versions of morty are repeating old gags
from previous seasons which of course is
a big callback to the meeseeks episode
where they all start going crazy the
writers and the animators also said they
had a bit of a contest to see how
creative they could get with the way
Morty
took out all these people my favorite is
probably the gun that slices all these
cars and people up into a bunch of
different pieces then the pieces grow
legs and start running off in all
different directions also creative
points for the molecular destabilizer
that shoots them with what looks like
DNA strands just destabilizing their
molecular structure you also notice that
Dan Harmon is voicing the news anchor
that is gas lighting his co-anchor while
this is all going on and Rick winds up
in a teddy bear Rick which you think
would be the cutest reality but also
winds up being super peace I'm
out of here
Morty in the courtroom facing the judge
also kind of reminded me of the judge
Morty short from a couple seasons ago if
you pause the news broadcasts and you
read the tickers they also you
these for some meta jokes to making fun
of the way people pronounce Lacroix or
La Crosse no matter how you pronounce it
you still look stupid when they start
cutting to the scenes of other people
watching the news broadcast you look
over on the right here in what looks
like a version of Times Square there's
an ad that Justin roiland worked into
the background of the episode for his VR
game called Rover saves the universe
this is an actual real ad for a game
that you can buy in real life right now
really big that morty turns down
naked jessica because he thinks the
crystal wants into number 4 wasp erick
for the win the writer said that they
wrote him to seem like the most terrible
version when he first shows up but
somehow the most empathetic despite the
fact that he's been through all these
realities he drops a joke about
morty being stuck in a bunch of bad
political message boards they feast on a
bug version of mr. goldenfold and
somehow have the most loving family
relationship of any of the realities
that we've seen so far
when they make it back we find out that
rick has been keeping a special boggler
creature in a box we don't know exactly
what it does but they'll probably pay
that joke off later this season or a
future season so just open up a bookmark
in chrome for that they make a joke
about the Red Kirkland brand meeseeks
boxes if you don't have one of those in
your area there's just a giant discount
Walmart type of business they generate
red meeseeks that are super sucky the
hologram comes back and drops an Isaac
Asimov reference from iRobot about the
Three Laws of Robotics the greatest of
which is that they're never supposed to
harm humans number three Morty goes full
akira in the wastelands with one of
Rick's weapons
you wonder why Rick has this and what he
was intending to use it for eventually
but then the hologram winds up getting
turned into a Kyra Rick with the
ferrofluid made flesh and goes on a big
rant about how he was lying about being
super PC intolerant the entire time
again because the show typically doesn't
want to take too many sides that's why
Rick at the end of this says there's a
lesson here but somebody else is going
to be the one to figure it out they pay
off the joke about wasp Rick laying eggs
in people's eyes and then number two the
ending of the episode
Rick and Morty both recite the message
of the episode Morty's saying don't be
so worried about the future that it
prevents you from being happy in Rick
saying you should probably worry about
the future a little bit Rick makes a
full house reference Jerry directly
references akira in anime then they
break the fourth wall
when they're talking about how they'll
do classic stuff sometimes and other
times they'll do brand-new weird stuff
and sometimes they'll go all Seinfeld
and they won't do anything in episodes
Mordy also references the hundred years
of Rick and Morty rant from season 1
episode 1 just calling back to that and
then they break the fourth wall again
when they yell at summer for ruining the
season 4 premiere number 1 was the
post-credits scene where they revealed
that future that Morty saw in the
crystal was totally misleading in
Jessica was just a hospice care worker
who comforted people who had totally
been alone and didn't have anyone Morty
just submits himself to the worst things
Rick can think to do to him hey not
going to waste this opportunity and then
there's a tag scene honoring Mike Mendel
who was their longtime lime producer and
friend who recently passed away it was a
really tragic event it shook them up so
that's why they put this at the end of
the episode but if you did spot any
Easter eggs during the episode that I
didn't mention in the video just write
them below in the comments I'll be doing
a trailer video for season 4 episode 2
that should post by tomorrow I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post that
everyone click here for my new season 4
trailer video with a bunch of new scenes
from future episodes and click here for
all my other Rick and Morty Easter egg
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys tonight!